they'll take their swings off the
right-hander matt harvey the dark knight
will try to rise after his worst start
of the season
seven earned runs he gave up in four and
a third you see what he's done in the
year he's three and three with a 4-8 era
11 walks 29 strikeouts opponents hitting
267 off the right-hander
two down g-man choice steps in and just
came back he had his right knee scoped
and he lost him ball four so a two-out
walk to choi after a couple of pop-ups
on the right side that gets brandon loud
to the plate hit hard right field
stewart coming hard dives and makes the
catch nicely done by d.j stewart harvey
only has to throw a few more pitches
after the miss strike
and you know tonight might be the night
wayne that luis patina was treated like
a a traditional start he got stretched
out his last time out he threw four
innings 65 pitches i think kevin cash
would be willing to let him get to that
five mark up the pitch count cedric
mullins will lead off in the bottom of
the first against luis patino swing and
a miss he just eviscerated him with a
fastball right there at about 96. so one
down for austin hayes there's a
beautiful slider in hayes
just got caught looking and that's the
second strikeout for patino two going
nobody aboard here in the first for trey
mancini there's a swing and a fly ball
to center field
gonna back up phillips a step or two but
he's got plenty of room makes the catch
and it's a one two three
bottom of the first for luis coutinho
done with one no score and the rays have
on a weak ground ball and a blooper
first and second here's brett phillips
he's at 224 on the year lifted to deep
right field we had a bleeder we had a
bloop and now we got a blast brett
phillips with his second home run
of the season and he's given the raise a
three-nothing lead
here in the second on a 2-2 pitch i
think they had the back gate open and
that wound up
out there on utah street a three-run
home run
well you don't always have to hit it
over that gate back there runners on the
corners first and third one down austin
meadows with an rbi opportunity there's
a high shot back into deep right center
and that one is going to get out of here
home run way over that 373 marker up
into the stand and austin meadows on low
the raise
with a pair of three-run home runs in
the second inning breakout in front six
nothing and it is the toughest orioles
night so far for harvey who was out of
the game
after dinning in two thirds
now here is the pitch of mike zanino
with the infield end and the fastball
hammered deep into center field way back
at god
well over the 410 marker
a two-run home run
off the bat of mike zanino wendell
scores in front of him
and the rays make it an eight nothing
ball game hitting
their third home run
in the last inning plus now orioles with
runners on the corner starting the
bottom of the third time for a little
action from austin hayes bounced up the
middle into center field orioles on the
board an rbi for austin hayes as stevie
wilkerson scores still nobody down those
get on the board they trail the race
eight to one bottom of the third
and it was a little more elevated this
time fastball away these have not all
been drilled by the orioles this thing
but they will probably do a couple of
these
follows with a broken bad single and
then hayes with a three or four hopper
adamus is so good at shortstop
one of the best in the game
but he was played to pull
six strikeouts for moutinho tonight a
couple of walks putting up a run on four
hits orioles have two on with one down
and steve wilkerson steps in wilkerson
swings he drives the ball into right
field for a base hit getting the
go-around is galves charging in for
third and safely is cisco and it's
another rbi this time for stevie
wilkerson with a single
those continue to cut into the lead
eight to two
bottom of the fourth
well how about you stevie wilkerson
welcome back to the big leagues
didn't play in the big leagues at all
last year another fastball on the inside
pardon he does the same thing he did his
first time he quickly gets the hands in
and drops a barrel to right field
orioles down 8-2 they got him loaded one
down
austin hayes at the plate one for two
night for him bounced up the middle
to second for one on to first hayes beat
it out
and the orioles get a run orioles trail
eight three bottom of the fourth they've
got runners on the corners again mancini
swings this is a line drive into left
field and comes stevie wilkerson rbi
single trey mancini
and the orioles continue to chip away
here they've cut the lead in half eight
to four
here's zanino cenino struck down and hit
a two-run home run as last time there's
a swing and a drive toward left hayes
going back at the track looks up good
bye
mike cedino with his second home run of
the night
and he's
enlarged the raised lead again it's 10-4
good buddy and boy the rays
who saw that lead dwindled to four
can use that it's now 10-4 that was one
of those ones that got lost up in the
sky and
just dropped into the lower deck of the
left field
to call those a home run
hitters home run
and here's brandon lau and now reaching
out there's going to drop a base hit
into the left
that's going to score rosarina and
heading into third base just ahead of
the throw his meadows the rays pick up
another run
second hit of the night for brandon lau
his 18th run bad ahead double the lead
off the eighth from meadows
against armstrong so it's a runner at
second and now g mon choi list one in
the air it is straight away center field
pushing mullins back all the way back to
the wall number one for g mon choi it's
a two run homer and it's 13 full rays
over the 410 marker
joy on the first pitch
unloads and hits his first home run of
the year
and just like that the rays had two more
runs and it's 13-4
jeffrey springs will be the new pitcher
pitcher number six for the rays in this
13-4 ball game
well and dwayne our game summary here
i'll tell you it has been all about the
long ball zanino's got a couple of them
brett phillips got it started in the
second inning austin meadows followed
him up with a big blast g-man choi got
involved and the o2
lined the right side and through base
hit veleka
mancini chugs around to score stewart
goes first to third
it's an rbi single for pat balayka and
the o's are within a touchdown it's 13-6
now the o2 here's the swinging ground
ball toward third padlow has it throws
across in time in the rays
are victorious
so the rays scored early and often
and then started to add on
and in game one of their three-game set
in baltimore